well there is well Andrew Santino I'm
back to defend my title as the best
podcast guess that's only done this
[ __ ] thing one time it was an amazing
episode it was incredible and all these
people are Theo von in and crystalline
but those guys suck ass I'm here to
fight
I'm here to fistfight and I'm ready to
win I just want to do a podcast I won't
fight anybody and I'm gonna go sit and
wait for shop
I guess Kalin [ __ ] up huh he's not
here another thing to tell you ah what's
up brother what's up you know Carolyn is
suppose he's on set he's me little late
today but and I interrupt you for a
second please do bro brian is such a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
we texted him and I five or six times to
make sure that this is confirmed and I
said I'm so happy to be back with you
guys sure enough he's not here
he texts to lea and itís no you texted
Leonidas morning were still on supposed
to be me you too Leon Kallen I was
checked with the guests in the morning
it's called boom refresh national you're
a pro I'm pro right guys dude
Santino D'Elia tomorrow yep I'm like all
right are you a man I haven't heard
anything about I talked to Chris
everyday Chris hasn't mentioned it so
I'm like ah Brian gots this no it takes
you guys nothing nothing I texted you
back
you didn't chris goes what today today
today is the day you gotta keep me a
little bit more abreast
so when Callen does come in if he does
come by in a Sock'em we're gonna knock
him the [ __ ] out stupid when I knock him
out
do you imagine Brian can fight can Brian
fight he can't he's so handsome
well he can is suppose for his age who
would you put him against well who what
others 67 year old would you put him
against I mean Rogen's only 50 but Ron
Rogen would row in 12th is Hannah him
who's somebody that he'd have a good
competition fighting like a legit fight
yeah who would be a good fight cuz you
know Delia Delia I think would murder
Lee would [ __ ] murder younger he got
a lot of readers he's big you gotta go I
like you and Cal would [ __ ] fight
we'd be a good fight he's older than me
by a little but we would be a good fight
stick it don't my favorite I think Bryan
and I have the same kind of like we have
the same kind of anger like I yeah we
have the same kind of like you know
Bryan's really nice and sweet but inside
deep down he's dark dark dark some would
say the
darkus you know I don't get a dark vibe
from you I got it in there dude they're
gonna realize I got a real deep it's
just like old [ __ ] boy that boils up
because you were pig glass all the time
as a kid growing up no no I'm no I'm
just bringing up dude on brainstorming
no I'll tell you what it was uh Oh
actually know exactly what it was when I
was a kid having red hair used to be so
annoying because people would talk [ __ ]
but I would only use my hands and not my
words I learned to use my words and be
funded originally you bought every one
that came in my way I punched everything
I fought everybody ting so then I got a
guy I kind of got the card of a bully
but all I was doing was defending myself
but I would I would punch everybody you
see you you know what they say they
can't do that a little bit of anger
issues a lot of it I had to go to
[ __ ] anger management I have a lot of
anger they kicked me out of us of my of
my elementary school or whatever slugger
Santino that's one of the teacher says
well Gerson that's a nun said I was in a
half of school they kicked me out
you named your next special Slugger
Santino yes yeah because I fought too
many kids Wow
because it was validated because they're
roasting it right here yes so they would
say you know fire crotch or under what
was the other one I was really good maid
of faith tomato face yeah pizza boy yeah
it was just like what whatever for
whatever [ __ ] they could come up with so
when you're that young most people don't
think that you're gonna punch him they
think you'll push them or you'll yell at
them or whatever I would just punch
people as hard as I could
well well I feel like most kids
especially begin roasted are gonna punch
so as they could
you're not gonna dissect someone with
your words but you know most people
don't want to fight that's something you
know don't you know that most people in
this world try to avoid fighting now
especially but back to how old are you
with 75 yeah what's a exact same age but
back when I was a kid be like most
problems were solved with your fight it
wasn't a big deal
no you died endurance I didn't get
suspended for weeks or nothing like that
like the teacher like what happened I'm
like he was making fun of my mom [ __ ] so
mean him start wrestling and I punch
from the faith like I see you're in
detention you're here the good days he's
the good old days yeah when you didn't
have to worry about it I remember being
a redhead these days please well nice to
meet beasts knives guns yes I think
people use people use real [ __ ] now
people are gonna use real weapons now
when they fight but imagine
being redhead right but the lease you're
good we can do it imagine you do it
because most of them are [ __ ]
religious red-headed people I know and
they look at me as if to say like hey
I'm also ready oh I look away I go no no
no [ __ ] my old we're different
it ruins my day we're different now
imagine being that red shitty redhead in
school oh you're not being a dime piece
because there's some hot ones yeah
there's some wild chicks mostly that's
what I'm saying that was good-looking
dude
but Canelo is but but Canelo is got that
spice he's got that that Mexican spice
yeah but his skin is looks like a
vampire
it does but he's still because of the
Mexican is still helped true any [ __ ]
but what I'm saying is imaginary in a
redhead kid who doesn't look like the
slugger Santino or Canelo and gets
picked on and on themselves and then
goes home and you get bullied on moi
boys mean right that means flying tomato
[ __ ] freckle-faced can you believe
can you believe that there's a kick a
ginger day that still exists I think the
government-sanctioned I don't even know
what the Jane is do you know what the
kicker ginger day is I don't know it's
an official day that people publicly
online nobody gives us credit for being
a minority that gets picked off the most
famous flying tomato I mean I would say
there's so many different levels of it I
would say like the most famous comedians
of all time that are famous Arbour and
Louie
they're both redhead both redheads the
most angry or or carrot-top SAS who
oddly enough is extremely famous people
didn't say what they want he limit yeah
he kills it in Vegas so I went to a show
to me was actually good
what are you doing this he's doing
something right yeah but he's what he's
doing is he's found a market that he's
stuck with no one else stuck with that
he's found a niche that works right yeah
that's great and then who else is the
most famous redheads I'm trying to think
of like football players well there's a
bunch of them did Alton Carson Wentz I
mean um
are you trying to clean Carson Wentz
isn't he kind of he's like an augury of
Carson woods so it's back for the
Philadelphia jolliness huh November 20
November 20th is kick a ginger day so
it's coming up oh no no we probably miss
it
I don't even know what [ __ ] dead ship
next year you kick me please
[Music]
Carson Wentz no Carson Palmer Oh Carson
Palmer's knees are red it is not don't
try and claim win no I won't look at
Carson Palmer he's a redhead right
varnish oh god yeah not really
Andy Dalton is a redhead see that yeah
right there kinda looks these are ready
look his facial hair he's got the red
beard
Andy Dalton is a redhead Andy done
anyone really good though
oh come on no not really there's no what
what there's no really good think of
anyone there's never been a pro
red-headed at basketball player I don't
think not that I can think I'm just like
the tall 7-footers but they're never
very good no no no a couple of redheads
than there be typing redheads MBA from
the gym I guess yeah climate comedy got
you piece of [ __ ] you oh my god look
what he's wearing by the way I took over
your chair yeah I did yes it is bright
what time are we supposed to start this
whole thing I'm shooting my TV show why
I'm wearing my that's you wanted to wear
that J did your call is until 5:00 p.m.
today that's rude yes it is dude your
did you just like wearing that around
town cuz you want people to ask you
correct hey were you the guys from the
trip I saw you on the trailer on ABC
rekt he still rocks a MADtv shirt yup
fresh from set really is that a hangover
jacket
he's just rockin all your [ __ ] that you
don't have to wear this because I'm it's
very cold and you guys are outside it's
the beginning of December are you taking
a shot excuse me well you know what
let's sit let me take a shot I saw hey I
saw your I know you are I saw your
trailer for this on ABC last night and I
was gonna congratulate you but you were
in it you're barely in it so it's at
school I know you know what it's at
school and show details it's gonna
chicken Tim Meadows it's the chick show
brought to the main trailer don't ever
Maine traveler main trailer you're the
third leading trailer you're the third
lead no three get racy hot girl Tim
Meadows Bryan Callen take your hot girl
one 97 and a half real quick I've been
hitting hot girls we all know hot girl
check checking Meadows definitely no
checks on that live ladies man
Bryan Callen Bryan Callen third
hey when you go do pictures for that
when you go do pictures for uh for press
you know when they're on the when you're
on the step-and-repeat
they go tomatoes tomatoes and a girl
they go whatever her name is Jay Jay
Jake's and they go this way this way
right this way right this way to get out
of a shot shot shot let's go hey ten
minutes come back demos they let baby
but I don't do these did they let
background do these story Wow all the
extras on there now because you're late
look at his [ __ ] god damn it sit down
tight take your [ __ ] iphone 10/10
this is the s is that the ex do you like
the to me though they gave it to me they
gave it to me David yeah that's true I
got friends in high places
oh my god this outfit is so nice stay
standing up real get the rump rump on
this man thanks for coming bright no
it's my podcast no and by the way I want
to say this about you know it's the
fighter in the slugger
he just invited himself on I get a text
that goes hey dude I'll see you December
5 yep I love what cats because we were
on here I was talking about how funny on
you'd launch new podcast I'm about your
logo on here yeah see deal talked about
I said we got to get you on thank you
well you're welcome for probably
boosting your numbers and thank you so
much for coming letting me come Bob and
thank you so much for coming to my
podcast with shop know you're late its
new podcast bro let's let's talk about
this so yeah yeah I asked you to come
back I said I'm gonna come back on you
know why yeah because all of the fans
and your you guys's fans are the [ __ ]
yeah I love all your fans yeah and they
say oh you know Julia guest of the year
Theo Theo guest of the year that whole
thing I've only done this one time
my one time was better than all of the
times those guys they did love you I'm
gonna let me take some I've heard CEO a
man's leg at that I've heard him I've
heard him a lot done okay hold on done
well that broke my hand my dad lives in
a sewer
done yeah man you see rat tails done
okay don't done that's done man you're
some kind of done you know why why
because my name wasn't in the
conversation at all and then someone put
something online that said what about
Santino vo came after me he did yeah
he's very protective of this
he's very I never said I wanted the belt
I'll say this now that he's running out
how to created this come on let's go
[ __ ] Brendan can attest to this
our fans are unforgiving and have they
basically like very I told Brian I told
Brian now listen we got different now
listen we've been doing pockets for this
fire 800 episode yeah even though it
only says what our foreign before I've
been podcasts for a long last time right
we've had our ups and downs the last few
weeks we've had some tough guests and
here's what I tell Brian like our guest
it's just that the fan like you who are
the guests right [ __ ] on anybody the
point is that our our our fans are very
particular about who they really like
here's what I say who here's what I say
if you're not good on this show same as
if you're on a lot of other shows but
for a reason we have this loyal fan base
yeah if you're if you're bad on here
it's gonna hurt you more that's gonna
help definitely nobody's nineties your
show no one's falling you heart around
the show for so long now that's
[Music]
big apertures I'll juice a big bird it
was a big bursting it's rough in there
that's so hey man by the way I get so
many messages from your fans that go
dude you and job together what a killer
combination so good and they go they go
Shabbos [ __ ] he's like so personable
and lovable and cool and good look in it
and you're so funny and sweet and
awesome and smart and then go ahead and
Brian also is sometimes around and it's
a show and what a cool try you one guy
just sent me a meme over this plane
going this is Brian every podcast and
don't shoot this guy with fake guys it
really makes me angry
does that make you mad
yes man you look really good thank you
hey man all that money and they still
gave you Reba by the way my psoriasis is
gone look at that [ __ ] thank you Dan
Garner 88 at gmail you had psoriasis
dude I work with this guy Dan Garner
help me with I had to bring it up sorry
but he brought he changed my life I have
so he did of the liver no he helped me
out change my gut biome how did you how
do you get psoriasis is that it's a
stress but also there's an imbalance in
your gut what they're finding is a lot
of autoimmune diseases
lupus all kinds stuff might be
rheumatoid arthritis might be an
imbalance in your gut here's the other
thing he's oh yeah Andrew when you get
older how many medications are you I
mean every day you take what seven or
eight how many pills just to get rolling
you know I take talk about the stupid
stretches you do before you I take I do
my yoga I do my yoga what position is
your why my energy I March you both you
both are straggling you know that what
hold on hold on well let's let's be I
run six or seven miles every single day
I know let's get out there bro listen
listen listen you see him on the street
throwing about me to know and I and I
get it and I give you both a great known
as you're talking to him don't this
Energy's not even it to you to cuz I'm
gonna tell you we're here to me two
additional reason why be careful I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up your Kirk do you listen
you guys are big and strong and God
bless correct well all that stuff yeah
now listen cool good guys no hold on
I got two things going on and it's not a
big deal what is it not your hairline
hold on I'm holdin my mind I can shut my
mind off and I know what to think about
what not to think about I can
compartmentalize like nobody's business
that's okay that's okay
you guys are young no hold on and here's
the other thing strong mind you say
here's what a strong line well I mean if
I gotta shut it off and then turn
another particle parain on yes then then
then that's what happens okay yeah cuz
why why right why why well been getting
ready for that moment my whole life your
whole life okay no that's okay had more
practice been in the ring longer than
you guys in our life longer ring now
another ring a long turn it was twined
it was just like hand maybe that's a new
but I'll give him that
yeah when they're fighting basically
oven mitts there wasn't any kin there's
everyone like the the ring by ring you
mean the crowd like it was the
Donnybrook me they're just a bunch of
chickens and you're like walking around
before plastics came along and
refrigeration
before refrigeration of plastics but now
listen to me the other thing my body's
built for one thing and it's not a bit
so I'll give you the mind control check
it's built my body's built to [ __ ] to
bear down and when I got a bear down I'm
bearing down I'd be giving some examples
so much to move around give us an
example feel good and you're at the
front of the pack but when it comes down
to actually the long march when that
when the fight goes into round 15 and 16
and that I think said very old it's very
old it's been for quite a while down
when the cartel captures our bus and
says you guys are gonna be that we
haven't slept we haven't eaten we
haven't had any water and now they give
us hammers and they go you guys gonna
fight it out and the winner joins the
cartel you think you're gonna beat us
with hammers the thing is you get
[ __ ] what round it is dad it ain't
how high
Hey what the [ __ ] was that hopper Papa
Papa please Papa please don't call me
Papa please call me Dad don't pop I know
you I got up at your heart I got your
ticker don't do that GABA you know what
happens when your ticker gets all
chipping jumpity Papa please your Beach
open you Papa please no Papa last time
we had to take you to the hospital and
you were there for weeks and weeks
because your your ticker look at the
floor boy I gotta take you out with this
hammer look at the Papa look at the
floor let's put it this way let's say we
all jump into the ocean be let's say we
all jump in that freezing cold ocean
there you feel style you think comes out
alive the water breaks let's sleep and I
need my cold and water the cold turns me
into a coward so okay so you're [ __ ]
during any kind of war scenario and pop
outside unless you're in Iraq but I'm
not good with the Cold War three comes
along although when I said when I was in
the Missouri Breaks I go to get my feet
when Tom and I couldn't walk I yeah now
they're cold the coal to break anybody
down know who I feel I can you got you
can kind of conserve heat for a while
your your probably built do you know
what that just was that was a shot I'm
serve heat is like a fat that's a fact
Wow that's a quick your kidneys are
always warmer than mine
that's a consumption of fat thing that's
what that is dig bro there's a
subcutaneous layer that's all in the
wall I'll say this if we all die you'd
be the last person we'd eat that's right
you see there's nothing there dude look
at how garbage this meat would be more
garbage no because it's barren dry rub
ribs your body is about is made for
[ __ ] it's made to get to get to
crunch down and [ __ ] take the
onslaught
you're at your Outback Steakhouse steak
that's what this would be really great
man drew stay down Angele control your
breathing breathe with me come on it's
okay we are gonna die but don't worry
Jim what's the worst like cheapest food
at the North Korea at this North Korean
barbecue just Korean Bob what's the
cheapest North Korean barbecue they've
got Wow Wow I apologize
even chin did a spiritual a I got
nervous about it I was like oh yeah
we'll figure it out
what's the worst cheapest shittiest food
eating well the cheapest one is called
Chavo but it's actually delicious
what's it called shadow shadow you know
you Chad owe you a delicious but you
were all guide your child out now you
got to spice me up you're cheap and
gross but you're delish you gotta beat
my meat against the rocker cuz it's
gonna beat it against the rock can you
imagine Bryan Bryan dies you've got
you've got his arms I've his legs and
were just beating his body against a
rock your breakdown is you know it's
weird yeah I can that would work so so
I've done all your little fragile bones
because you know those are old bones
don't say a frat there's no calcium Leto
there is no way I bet you if I kick your
leg right now I'd break it no I swear to
god Rico's I check it yeah I know
no you oh no mootai I choose even when
you check I'd break on the table watch
you get and you hear this nope I go and
you oh my foot taught me my foot nope
cuz those bones against my shin that has
no feeling left I got anything left
everywhere maybe I'm dad dude
guess who started a podcast yeah now
guess who did you I I'd hate to be
shitty here Andrew did you give him the
okay to start podcast did you I didn't
either I did it's weird
yeah he's I could've swore we run this
town
yeah and by telling mean podcast if we
want to turn people against your podcast
hmm believe me I gotta do is float a
couple rumors though is the bun right
here is that the button yeah let me tell
you a couple reasons why you shouldn't
push that button all right I'm gonna
listen first of all always been a fan
and a friend of you shop you know that
say no one
well no you got you do good at
negotiating
second of all you only think I do me
you've always been hyper pay the piper
I'll pay the piper
yeah we'll see Mel I know you run the
block I'll come give you a little how
you do you yeah I'm do what I'm supposed
to do and maybe what hour because I wish
need to talk dog blow town this is bull
runs to [ __ ] okay okay so I was not
ignorant I'm arrogant but I'm not
ignorant hey Rob take your finger off
the button I just did
man all right we're back it's good to be
honest with you baby yeah [ __ ] talk
into anything
I know man I know I can't it salesman
hey I'll sell you something what's your
least favorite food on earth I mean for
me I can't stand tongue Steve beef
tongue beef tongue is disgust I hate all
those I could never eat olives I'm gonna
pitch Baldy at the exact same time
because I've been selling beef tongue
Alice for about 26 years ago into town
selling I would say you're a purveyor of
olives and tongue well sometimes I do
stuffed olives with tongue beef tongue
we do stuff no way I can eat that let me
tell you why why is it we marinate it
for four and a half hours yeah in virgin
vert virgin
put plus uses origin pose Jesus Wow
delicious it's good for your health good
for your eyes yeah RiRi grows your bones
in your body
yeah we've been testing it for about six
or seven months now everybody we've
tested is it put muscle on you probably
not absolutely does you know Chris
D'Elia you know that guy is the comedian
version of me
yeah but bigger with real muscles like
real honest man you like culinary used
to look like that oh wow nope it's from
your beef tongue from our beef your
stuff our beef beef tongue olives double
beef tongue olives why are you pushing
this from female beef beef juice peafowl
of beef beef beef cow tongue beef it's
cow con they're called beefy conk conk
out some olives now we sell them in most
Koreans with cow [ __ ] and that would be
in Hong Kong cow tongue [ __ ] its carrion
what do we call it how come town can
talk there it sounds I'm kind of in and
can I tell you a whole jar of this thing
five bucks
yeah I got so much money five bucks so I
just think give it a whirl what do you
think the answer is yeah buddy jars two
or three let me start with ten and we'll
go from there all right sound all right
sold you saw what just happened so I you
ever sell anything like that growing up
any side gigs I would this is insane
when I was in high school my senior year
I got a job at a telemarketing found
like an ad in the paper come in 20 bucks
an hour when I was in high school all
right money all right
great money all I had to do was make
cold calls then sell window-washing
power-washing air duct cleaning it's a
tough gig though oh not for old enough
for old ginger not frills
that's liar in the game really I would
beat out adults who needed that money to
like feed their families I got a bonus
every single [ __ ] ma when I went away
to college those guys were so mad they
gave me $1,000 to like be like hey
congrats you helped us out so much this
crud yeah pick up the phone pick up the
phone ready yeah hello hey how how you
know mr. Callen how are you today who is
this oh sorry about that uh my name is
Andrew I'm working for this company
we're actually doing your neighbor's
house right now well then we just need
access to his house for your yard do you
mind mr. Johnson your next or neighbor
who you know very well oh yeah yeah yeah
he spoke very highly of you by the way
he actually said that new car that you
just got to sees a little jealous that
and your wife but so we need access to
his house through your yard yeah that's
absolutely that find you were doing his
air ducts cuz good god you wouldn't
believe the amount of dust and pollen
that's getting stuck in these air ducts
these days I mean we're doing his for
super cheap because he's a friend of
ours and we'll be there for about you
know I don't know half a day on Tuesday
should we just bounce over to your you
know what have you had your air ducts
clean that recently or no I've never had
my own I've never had them cleaned every
my oh my god and a good-looking guy like
you with a beautiful wife like you've
got him and you guys want to live for a
long time you want to you want to be
making love for years and years to come
because I could tell you know a young
strapping beautiful man like you we need
people like you on this earth to
procreate so let me tell you something
I'm gonna run over to your house I'm
gonna clean your air ducts at half the
cost half the cost of what I was gonna
charge Wow
yeah only cuz you know mr. Johnson and
he's just such a good dude and he said a
lot of good things about you so half the
cost will be over at noon on Tuesday
we'll be done that is that sound good
let me write I'm gonna put in the work
order right now all right
have a good day mr. Kallenbach Wow clean
air ducts and I'm gonna do that I was 17
years old and I would do that and I
would sell [ __ ] good at it I remember
to this day I sold seven thousand
dollars worth of air duct cleaning power
washing and window washing seven
thousand way with their word sir oh now
now I sold supplements door-to-door like
pursuit of happiness didn't go as well
that's so hard when they see you with
the it's easier to sign this is back in
there when people have house phones
anyway yeah can't sucker people on cell
phones anymore
they're trying though hey what are you
doing it's usually a guy on his couch
watching TV in Chicago and he's like a
stone
dude I don't have time for this and
you're like no it's fine I just need
access I need you to say yes to be on
your property yeah what are you doing on
my property
no no I'm pounding your neighbor's
property I just if we were accessing the
back we don't want you to be served we
don't want if you have animals we just
wanna make sure they're not
bothering you or your family yeah and
they go what are you doing what see
what's he doing yeah he's just getting
his windows wash I mean he hasn't has
why why well actually there can be like
you know cracks and chips that come in
the winter because of the you know
different wind chills so we're gonna
clean his windows because actually the
debris causes more damage to them then
you have to get all new windows and
that's thousands of dollars anyway I'm
gonna let you go
that's so dude you're so so time-life
books over the phone yeah for a summer
that didn't go as well no no no you tell
me you get out you get all nice things
neighbors know me a book bright well III
would basically go how are you is is
this who is this mister Santino yeah
it's me mister Santino time-life books
here well if you're interested in
cooking but we have an amazing special
on ten books I'm out I hung up track try
selling supplements I would drive your
first pitch was I don't know if you're
interested in cooking I donno if you're
interested in cooking hanging up are you
a man with food who likes it clay my man
you like no my manager was so good he'd
go like this he'd go how are you this
evening
yeah can I ask you a question to go
write it up and he'd already saw that
yeah he was dude I would go door-to-door
to gyms right in houses I'd go to in the
gyms like shitty gyms with like soccer
moms and I'd get with the manager I'd
have like a whole briefcase full of
supplements and I'd say see that lady
over there one person you know one
percent better he's gonna make her
better boxer one percent you take this
she's one percent better and he'd like
there I was I sold nothing you but
nothing she's a soccer mom she does not
give a she leaves tell about your won my
set she needs it like they don't get a
[ __ ] I'd like in I'd name off all these
fighters or NFL guys he's like I don't
dude these kids are like 13 I'm like I
get that but if Deion Sanders took this
wouldn't it help this kid
like you get the [ __ ] out of here there
was a guy at hazard Gracie school back
in the day who was selling he was a
bodybuilder but he also would see was
selling supplements like minerals and
steroids and I remember him going I
remember him saying something like you
know I'm trying to get pencil to have
take some of these minerals because
these things will make you 40% better
now think about how great heads was can
you imagine him 40% better look at
everyone I could be with that see I went
in as a professional athlete former
fresh out they going one percent better
you're not getting any money from any
one forward one percent you guys say 40
percent you know you guys say 100 you
said I used to be you're still
professional athlete you don't think
that oh you know you know these they
don't think that it stays with you you
don't think are always a professional I
think once you were yeah I mean I'm not
competing I'm not in that anymore but to
get to that pinnacle level you you are
forever a rational athlete yes yeah I
guess I use so much in what I do now if
you comment podcast no but usually you
will always be a professional athlete to
get there is impossible what you did is
impossible
yeah it's impossible on paper it's
impossible interesting think about that
I think extremely minut population of
professional fighters yeah right yeah
compared to the 7 and 1/2 billion people
hmm you were one that was known
successful and then when you're done
doesn't mean you're that doesn't
discount what you did well I said this
to him the other day they're always
gonna be a professional athlete so so
here's what I said to him the other day
so we were talking about how they're you
know sometimes he's been doing stand-up
for not that long yeah sometimes people
go well you know you you kind of jumped
the line a little bit because you're
friends with all these people and stuff
you get oh you mean like this yeah you
mean how am I saying I said to him I
said he's he goes I know that and I said
hold on I said well you're you you when
you say you jump the line because your
friends are Rogen and myself and
everybody else who've been doing
stand-up for 15 20 years okay but I and
I know your road to get here was really
easy because you played football and
then you you became a professional
fighter and went through the the
Ultimate Fighter and got punched in the
face by monsters and won and lost that
have that eight years say what you will
what that eight years was was not only
experience you're drawing from and
talking about on stage but that was a
[ __ ] talk about pay dues yes and
and what happened was you came in with
people like me and Rogan and we knew who
you were and we loved you and we loved
you for what you were able to do and oh
by the way the biggest thing was you
were funny you were make
laughing right on stories so it if
anybody wants to take that route if you
if you call that jump in the line go
ahead if you want to take the route of
becoming a professional fighter you know
that that's the thing that people don't
realize it's like it is it's a might
well I said the reason why I bring that
I appreciate it be the reason I brought
it up is cuz we ask that the comments
are in a circle and this girl we all
know she goes we talk about something
you can't say her name
no we're I'm gonna say her name okay
thank you and so we're talking about
something the open if we're talking
about venues and I some about one that
was terrible and we're talking about
open mics and I see I've done a few but
you know my first job Mike was the life
fighting the kid 14 of people whatever
and she was yeah but you know you got
short cut in comedy everybody everybody
knows that and I think most people
thought I would defend it but I mean no
your hundred percent correct 100%
correct the reason I sell tickets cuz
the podcast we're gonna sell take it's
because you know Rogan Brian that's that
but she but she drives me crazy when
people say it though because last one
yeah it drives me crazy only because the
the shortcut was a student fighter than
a kid and figuring out ways to bring it
on like a six hundred why do people why
do people not be a that game where they
go the only reason that you is because
of XYZ
by the way as a flawed argument because
I hear that all the time that people use
that in every other instant not just
this everything it's like saying when
some bozo goes uh well the only reason
she's [ __ ] him is because he's rich
it's like yeah yeah yeah okay that's
attractive correct what what what did
you dig what was the perfect scenario
for you to be happy about Bally's okay
bang the broker who you have to go Dutch
with Denny yeah can you split this
yeah it's $8.99 I will say it I'll say
it I don't mean this [ __ ] I will say
that that in I truly believe that the
reason you are working a lot you're
talking to is roomie because you have
red hair I mean I want to say that don't
see I'm not I hate to say but let's be
honest that's the own they got a
checkbox you're not talents know they
got a checkbox I don't think you'd be I
don't think you'd be working or B I
don't think you'd be doing a lot of
snail
don't get mad bro don't give that bro
dude I'm talented I'm smart I'm
hard-working I'm on every single night
in my [ __ ] life you think it's the
[ __ ] red hair I'll shave this [ __ ]
writer off house it'll get more work no
don't don't Ryan don't you even start
with me right now okay just because
you're on a spin-off of the Goldbergs on
school and it's gonna do very well which
I'm proud of you for and I would never
down you for that don't take away my
ability my hard work my ethics I have
nothing in this business I came here
with no money I have no family I'm not
Jewish
I made it alone I made it alone Brock
hey I know that don't you know I'm Jude
you're turning the key on the red
Ferrari you want to [ __ ] rat me out
because I will burn out all over this
place I misspoke I misspoke I fired what
bro no I did my mom man you know better
because I've earned this no I know
you've earned did you earn your position
in this game I did with regular hair
here's the thing your regular hair no
I'm just saying regular hair all red
everybody knows that a ginger has you I
see you right away you do you do pop
yeah I pop yeah and I stand out okay
guess what I have to deliver harder when
they see your normal-looking hair ass on
stage they just go this is just a normal
goofy looking [ __ ] white guy goofy
I'm not well you are goofy looking oh
there's no doubt who says goofy those
years have been bowing out a little bit
as we've gotten older like doors these
hard doors that are Olson no death yeah
they've been bowing out audience don't
say Bowie I think we should pin him back
you should tie it you should tie floss
from one side to the other and pull him
back at night no that is a procedure
you've all went out yeah you should
you're like let's say for the reason say
Finn was born with huge yes the Sun
never hits his face okay one guy that
can fight this way so it's like jumbo
let's say you're selling good is it
where that collocation you know what you
know they can't they they snip it and
clips have been pulling back it looks
normal
well so kids don't get bullied anymore
so they see you also die kids you could
die you could dye your hair but they see
you want stage and they go let's see
what this [ __ ] regular Joe Schmo has
to do you come up there with some of
your you know jokes whatever I know know
someone we're good i watch actually a
couple nights ago and i thought wow
that's better than you know he used to
be okay and you and you'd sling your
jokes and they go good yeah I'm glad he
was good but he's normal I get up there
and they go
what is this guy what is this guy yoga
and then I [ __ ] murder and they go
wow yeah wow he overcame something do
you have any redhead jokes not really no
you never bring attention to the fact no
you know why burr burr burr said
something to me years and years ago
about it I think he had they say don't
do redhead and it virt 'only said don't
do redheaded stuff how much Italian I
think he was like why I think I had
asked him or something so was too on the
nose huh I was just insecure as [ __ ]
when I first like to even talk to him
and I was like whatever and then and
then I think I had said I got a I don't
want to do that right I did like maybe
I'll read hit a joke and then he was
like you why well you don't need to why
does it why do you care it was something
along those lines I don't remember the
exact but it made me think about cuz he
doesn't do it so I was like oh he
doesn't do it ever ever what what is the
row no are you are you what are you
Italian and Irish half half Italian and
Irish Siciliano me too
you see the difference is I look I look
Irish yeah and I've got the body in the
[ __ ] of an Italian I don't know you look
like like a little tiny Swedish boy you
are like a little Swedish boy yourself
it may be little tiny Swedish boy I'm a
Brian a Calum yeah you know they're
tangible [ __ ] eyes Brian - Calum
that's an Irish girl and I and I know
horrible swims this is an Irish guy this
is clearly Irish man whoa do yes that's
Irish in Jamaican no this is Irish guy
that's so Jamaican this is I okay
welcome to Ireland no that's no welcome
to the island of Ireland man the very
land come over get some fish and chips
and fruit and salad no see that falafel
this is Ireland
salad couscous on the island of Ireland
no that sounds so Jamaican it's not even
close did you make in Jamaican accent
you want to join I a I'm Jamaican I'm a
big black Jamaican guy
everyone knows I'm Jamaican best
Jamaican super Australian you're so bad
with dialects
you don't know I don't I studied in
college dude I did dialectical research
that was one of my focuses what was your
what was your major in college
journalism and English journalist in
journalism major English focus and I had
a dialectic
subset I did
two and a half years of learning
dialects around the world Kay but name a
place and I can do it
Maori Maori you want Maori yeah okay
welcome to diesel nobody aiya aiya
poodle no mommy me hold you on daughter
sheep and you didn't understand the
language because I was also no he's okay
okay Russian Russian Russians probably
probably one of my favorites to be
honest with you Russians easy Russian
goes don't you want to eat you want to
eat fish with us or do you want to go on
your separate ways because dinner is
niet okay now I have to that's now looks
I don't take this wrong way but that
does sound a little bit French well you
you're going you want me to hear some
more big can I hear these and don't make
it okay don't make it can I hear it
Joplin is easy Japanese is probably one
of my favorite ones to do alright I have
to get prepped for it ready yeah did you
mine right who I dunno you know how to
do this with me I wanna dance on your
lap and maybe shake him up or supposed
to stop here because it's so good did
you just get transform like you were
back in Tokyo Japan I'm so [ __ ]
Spanish you guys are so wrong I maybe I
am I'm telling you you're wrong I went
to a [ __ ] school for dialectical
research okay maybe we're off I don't
maybe my go to college I did go did you
go to college or did with college I went
to American University in DC DC yeah
that's a really good school I know it is
what did you do what was your major
history economics in history then it was
history yeah economics and history well
it was economics and I switched over to
hist when was the war of 1812 that's a
good question
in the 1800's sometimes that is a good
school what did you go shop here you see
Colorado Boulder don't ask me anything
Rachel came you know what sports hooked
up with a girl there left a watch there
hooked up with hooked up with a - when I
was in college 100 fun in world dude had
myself a nice delicious
big piece of - we're on the heavy heavy
heavy I found her I mean she wasn't hard
to find hooked up with her left my watch
there nice fossil pet poor kid bad watch
never had a nice stop fossil you didn't
grow up with money no money had no money
I've made all my own money
Wow left watch there good cut and I
needed it that's how bad when it went
over to the two's house the next day
embarrassed you know what you have to do
watch walk of shame I had to kiss her
again and do all that stuff but do you
were glad you get your watch back
I needed that elegance you because that
that better watch in today like if I
left this nice watch leave it do you
think about I got money now think about
money do I think about it do you think
what is yeah what part of your brain
none I don't think about it
you know I don't know what because
you've had no money so you're not afraid
of not having money yeah it's fine
because some people are afraid I'm not
afraid I'm not afraid because I know
that I'm gonna keep climbing in this
business and keep working hard to do
well because if I don't and if it fails
okay I'll just go back home and just go
do some [ __ ] but I know it won't
happen yeah cuz you know why why - good
- good okay man don't be what do you
think I agree with him there
what are you doing what are you doing
dude you give us money what is that what
are those 20 s a bunch of hundreds oh
but you know what's so funny so
off-putting I have a tongue I have a ton
of them and hey and sometimes so just
for I don't know you know I have I got
him and then sometimes I'll go around
town get my way no I'll bury him just as
like a gift for someone if I be fine
that's good man yeah so your charity
thing yeah yeah all right sometimes I'll
Drive I'll Drive in my super fast car
and I'll Drive by like a skid row
downtown and I'll stop and I'll go do
who wants one of these
100 I'll go yeah they'll freak out you
know yeah yeah and I eat it because I
sometimes I wipe my ass with hundreds
yeah and I put in a ziplock like a bunch
of a bag of poo hundreds and then I go
and I go to old - like a like old old
homeless people like sad yeah you know
yeah ice em soup you know and I smack
them in the [ __ ] face with a poo
hunters and that's it and I take it back
you take it back wipe oh wow
them I think can I go you know what I
want it yeah and I keep my appetite Asst
you get hepatitis for Christmas and you
and I get my hundred back I go oh this
has poop on it and I wipe it on their
shirt that's so [ __ ] mean why do you
do the dude because I can't god damn it
man
no I don't think about money I don't
think about money by I'm very lucky I
didn't have any money I didn't have any
money what do you you grew up we grew up
fine middle class yeah whatever that
means gives you an edge I'm normal did
you grow up rich I mean yeah he grew up
favorite by that you mean I can just ask
my dad for any by that do you mean he
flew private as a child yes really well
I'm not a stranger to private I thought
it's what made Brian who Brian is a lot
of guys are just complete [ __ ] when
their dads are that rich but I saw a
picture I went to Brian's dad's house
this picture of Brian his sister young
as [ __ ] on a private jet Cheers
they're dolphins champagne like this and
they're like you're how old on the
corporate jet like 10 I was 14 old
enough to know better and old enough to
enjoy it and old enough to give
everybody who flies commercially the
finger older love some cash the point is
I think what daddy great I didn't go out
with crazy money but I grew up with
money I never had to worry that's a big
thing I never had to see the world was
very safe for me I never had to worry
about where my dollar came from which is
why I was a [ __ ] for a long time yeah
then you finally got it together kind of
well kind of but when you don't have to
worry when you know at the end of it you
have a net that at the end of the day no
matter what happens I can always go
daddy I need money what and so when I
was in when I was when I was in theater
school and acted in New York my dad P
went over acting did but how come you so
bad what do you think it's because I buy
that I think you know the history in the
economics thing I guess Andrew I do I
have $10 and someone takes two how many
do I have left
eight okay great great econ and great
history we learned both of these things
out of you but the acting thing is so
bad no dude you are so so bad that I
don't think I've ever seen one thing
that you do
Oh support line you know what fine give
me a scenario you're mine I'll give it I
made him an offer he can't refuse
all right go ahead I made him an offer I
can't refuse B - [ __ ] you Eve - dude do
you want to see how to really do it yeah
please okay how'd you get him now I have
to I'll give you the line to feed in
how'd you get him to agree the whole
let's start yet look see this one talk
about a mature an actor prepares dude
who you give us action
go ahead action how'd you get him to
agree I made him an offer he couldn't
refuse
and scene dude that's okay here's the
new see the difference do you see the
difference yeah I am moded more I turned
I did it-- there was body movements and
then you were saying when you were in
acting class though if it if it didn't
work out you were just gonna like [ __ ]
it go back to Papa
I had a no I mean no my ego was too big
that what saved me was the fact that I
just like being good at things I didn't
want to be the dork I want to be the
cool kid when I was the cool type a
personality I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
be not I'm not gonna not be successful
at something if I'm gonna go for it okay
why my boxing my dancing my [ __ ] my
acting everything so whatever but here's
the thing you're good at two of those
things don't dancing yeah don't say
boxing no not mocking all right what was
the other one
Oh [ __ ] you can dance and [ __ ] from
what I hear no I know it all right I
pounded this guy oh god I dude for your
fans by the way I'll take back all the
money jokes that I made cuz that's
that's disgusting that's not who I am
okay I want them to know that that's not
who I am this is a joke but what's not a
joke is I [ __ ] Brian Cal I have had sex
with Bryan Callen I want the world to
know man top top no no I'm bottom top
and the bottom and the top and the
bottom and the guy who films it out of
it yes you do yeah girls there goes our
whole [ __ ] secret no one know what
they gotta know
you're right let's say this right now my
boyfriend do you have any aspirations
attack we want to act act have an
audition tomorrow with John Cena but I
mean do you wanna do you want to act act
yes sirree sir do you want school [ __ ]
cool [ __ ] see that's no cat big kid I
was on set for a David Ayer's movie and
just being on that set for four or five
days I was like you want you want fun
cool [ __ ] like fun like real deep
dramatic pull out stuff you don't want
any of that stuff that's too much you
you don't only want to do comedy I I do
now because you're bad at drama no oh
I've seen some I know I feel like both
serious roles like Josh D'Elia he wants
to a similar Billy and I just talked
about it he wants to do he service Libra
here he wants to do action [ __ ] only
action [ __ ] that's what he's trying to
get apart trying to get big big and do
actions that's not gonna happen for him
why do you skinny skinny what do you you
want to do serious roles to know dude
doing the Showtime show for two years
was enough for me yeah I want to do
comedy for a long time so here just real
quick I want to do like a like an ABC
like a spin-off of the Goldbergs you
know like imagine if if they got a cute
girl to do a spin-off of the Goldbergs
so she's the lead yes she's the obvious
lead and then you know let then the
superintendent would be like I'm gonna
get you a part ok Meadows I'm like a
really good wealth of like oh sure
you like one of those good shows like
we're all familiar with them and exactly
and then I would be kind of the
hilarious comedic relief who's like
smart and good-looking and and dope it
sounds like good true that would be a
great get you a part on the show and
here's and here's the thing the token I
can make a call at any time to ABC and
get a job and have someone removed from
a job I thought I don't I won't do that
that is why would I be that kind of guy
do I have an old relationship with the
mouse I do you bet your ass I do
okay but what I ring of magnesia doodle
up the mouse and go hey you got a cut
Kalin and cuz you know what they would
say what say no more say no more you
don't have that kind of power and hold
yes I did Lee do but yes I do right well
you know you don't think I can make a
call right now have you I don't want you
to threaten why are you threatening me
because the what because the way you're
looking at me right now
I'm not looking at you in any way look
at job you better look at [ __ ] job
right now [ __ ] man
oh god you're power I had an acting
teacher you ever been in acting class
with it with a teacher I had a knack
teacher where we would do a scene he'd
be doing a dramatic scene and it's
nerve-racking and you're trying to be
good like you're trying to cry and I had
a teacher and my teacher would go like
this he'd go I don't buy in the middle
eocene you like trying to do your thing
dad why don't you love me I don't
understand whatever it is and it's
already embarrassing and you just hear
him go I don't believe you no acting
class have only done price habit
one-on-one well you never did
you never did class with pee I never did
a thing with other people you just did
one on once to get ready to training
with one on unit did you not study
you're a good actor you never studied
college I did theater okay I can't do it
barely what exactly is too busy getting
[ __ ] up I was bad
Oh College was tough on me do off so
I've had way too much fun my play I
finally watched dying up here I'll
finally watch dying up on the plane
there's a cup [ __ ] we're on planes oh
I'm getting those checks a lot of planes
it's so funny when you get the check and
you know home runs on planes it's on a
plane I don't know it was good it really
really good it was cool it was fun it
was - way too much drama
wait carry on the set ever Jim was there
sometimes
Jim deals with hey jim has so much on
his plate Brett really oh my god give
the show time shut up
no just cuz he's a busy at whatever Jim
wants to do he paints a lot yeah I know
he wants to paint so like painting is a
focus it'll take it's like saying but
that's not a lot on your table yes it is
it's like it's like saying your podcast
doesn't take up a lot of your time yeah
yeah it does it does it takes 8 hours a
day because because you have to think
about the painting hours a day I mean
but you all painting it just takes up
its that nobody commanding him to do
that that's of leisure Manning him to do
it just like you're demanding yourself
to do this yeah it's what I think he has
nobody but he but that's not a hobby to
him either no he needs to do the art my
feeling is that y'see I think that's one
of the reasons he occupies his brain in
different ways he likes to focus on
brain has to keep busy yeah otherwise
he's gonna [ __ ] wouldn't all of us do
more YouTube hey do didn't ruin my I
said you right now
if I say to you right now I'm gonna give
you five hundred million dollars but you
got to get the [ __ ] out of business you
can't do anything ever again nothing on
camera no speaking no nothing not
happening
yeah no you know why could you be like I
have this money and it's so boring let
me man I'm so [ __ ] gonna do the same
thing he has all that money good point
so without finding new focus he'd be
[ __ ] miserable good point then you do
kill your system dear talking about why
he doesn't act the way that you because
he's so talented well here's the new
show right bill yeah he's on it why he
doesn't do like old Jim Carrey stuff
well he was so good like I think in the
grand pantheon of comedians and comedic
actors you'd be hard-pressed to find
anybody who was better as dynamic as him
he's just he was able to do everything
the force I mean I think the only person
that was about had the ability that he
did but never got to breach it was
Farley probably Farley was from the only
guy who probably could had but a biggest
career in the world do it also does if
it can could do every ax owner here yes
his hair yeah he only has one special I
think it's like 30 minutes long you've
seen it at The Comedy Store yeah he
never wanted to do and I've talked to
him a bunch about that what's he say
stand up no no way what do you mean he
said no way I said all I said not now
we're not ever and he goes not now not
of course not now he's just not a fan no
no he just doesn't have that in him
right now I feel like he went to a
crisis I feel like he almost went
through a nervous breakdown
oh dude his his girlfriend killed
herself they blamed him and they blame
her her family blamed him which isn't
true she's even more flux insane which
was not true we all dropped all that
court [ __ ] was going away and in the
midst of that he was reinventing what he
wanted to be to the public again because
I think he had made some movies that
maybe he wasn't that stoked about yeah
you know I mean he made some great ones
though especially that serious oh dude
you know you're talking to me I'm a
massive man I mean I told him to his
face I'm like you're literally my hero
you're literally my communities and I do
comedies because I am is it but we would
and I said the same thing that Adam said
when I saw him I and I I don't feel like
it's the way to go I feel like they're
like oh no Jim she's almost better keep
it Jim knows how to receive it because
he knows that he was a hero to somebody
tech cop if you're a comic ii-if it's
just like a regular person on the street
that's like you the only reason I
breathe he's like that's [ __ ] weird
but to a comic to be like
dude you're the reason I do comedy
appreciate it he thinks it's beautiful
cuz it's like wow that's [ __ ] insane
that's how or another yeah person to
like really try to hone their talent but
yeah dude you guys know when you have
fans that talk to you on the street I
love when someone goes yo love your [ __ ]
dude whatever - yeah but when someone
goes Brian your ah your I love it dude I
want to be all you all the time you're
my guy yeah and you're like what we
don't make sense and they're not nervous
and they're like where are you going
what in Starbucks what do you get when
you're there oh no yeah I mean
everything just starts to like you're
like I just you got to go away yeah I
don't know there's worship and like
people are unhinged wide and I'm saying
I told my zyk do you the reason why I've
always wanted to stand-up comic somebody
I'm like no he's a goth cool man
preciate but I could almost if he was
almost like not they didn't appreciate
but he's almost like almost embarrassed
yeah you know he's just like he was like
I really appreciate it really
I know but but hmm but he lives in LA
right I just think if you're that famous
I just wouldn't live in LA anymore dude
I saw him I'd be like I'm gonna cook off
in in Malibu
yeah I'm not exaggerating he was with
his children for God's sake the guys
just trying to hang with his kids
everybody bro it was it was crowds of
[ __ ] and kids just one take pictures
with ya and they kept the kids and they
were they were mobbing him and everybody
can't get on camera it was just like I I
was like how would you even come to this
thing how do you even do you see a
special you so nice I did see a special
you want to talk about it sure it's
unequivocally the best special I've seen
in ten years
I can go out go on 108th a ton right
fantastic yeah I don't think so yeah I I
do I thought it was super rich let me
tell you why because all the special
that I've seen of all the people that
I'm friends with right now like guys
that I've seen like a Seguros new
special or Joe's you're special or guys
that are homies with me that I love them
and I watch them work out those jokes
it's amazing this was the first time in
a long time that I saw someone having
like a ton of fun
something did friend a lot of
carelessness in a really sweet way
that's why it just touched me it touched
me dude
it touched me in a way where I was like
we're supposed to be having fun - yeah
it
so much pressure and work and there's
all this like get a Netflix special can
you get n vision who's your hour with
you doing it yeah this is happening so
much now right now that everyone's
getting or you other thing what are you
doing the thing and when you doing the
thing that that was such a weird breath
of relief for me to be like I took the
checkerboard yeah he was like oh the way
she shot it was fun too because it's
from all these other [ __ ] venues where
it's cut and then the funniest no I'm
not saying it's the [ __ ] it didn't make
me like die laughing harder than any
other side watch the whole thing no and
me too but most even with our friends
like I'll get 40 minutes in I like I'll
check my phone my god it's also hard
because you've seen our friends material
for sure Baggins but that it was like so
different yeah music so I will say this
it's not the funniest special I've seen
in 10 years what it was the most fun
refreshing just Fonzie entertaining it's
just funny a [ __ ] talked about
pissing in the same place as kids bathe
that's and you'll see your song that UFC
[ __ ] was hilarious
the I watched the first 20 minutes
couldn't get through it
I wasn't that so I watched 10 and
stopped being my buddy Eric we were
watching and I go nah then he goes no
[ __ ] way and literally revisited a
week later sat by myself in a hotel room
watch it and I was like wow no this was
what this was I watched it in my Bobby
Boucher Jersey in my underwear
that's [ __ ] dope thanks dude if y'all
watch me seriously try to get on but
here go into it like this this isn't a
[ __ ] season veteran comedian who's
working out jokes and material to build
to a beautiful hour huh perfect rhythmic
different than what is a guy having fun
telling you stories and jokes and songs
that he's kind of accumulated to
performance it's a show it's a show yeah
imagine like if he did Adam Sandler on
Broadway this would be it yeah be great
you would love it it'd be great dude
also there's a song and I had an acting
teacher used to say like I didn't like
that movie and if he liked it he'd
recommend it or something or a book yeah
and he would always understand I didn't
like it he goes and he'd just go like
this you go watch it again that's it but
that true and it's true I've stopped
telling other comics about
other specials that I've watched because
every comic does is alright well thank
ya comics oh my god damn do anyone else
credit no it's impossible that's so
strange
yeah but that but but it's only because
it's pure and utter jealousy the only
person that people will give credit to
is Joe Joe's the only guy that I hear
that other comments go dude loved it
because they're scared of them okay say
that in the mic that's because they're
scared of him they [ __ ] right they
should be say it again because he's
awesome I fear no man
you don't fear Joe Rogan I don't feel
Joe Rogan I don't fear that [ __ ] guy
and I'll fear you it's weird crushes cuz
you don't think that Joe and job and I
could [ __ ] rip you to shreds ro do me
a favor if you decide to step into that
ring and I'm being dead serious let's go
I'm being dead so no gloves make sure no
gloves make sure clubs no gloves I'm
we're talking about a street fight make
sure well you set a ring bright make
sure you if you step over the line
we have gloves all right well if
somebody if we happen to cross a ring in
straightest is the Alzheimer's kick in
then do you see that you're all over bro
peace yeah that's all I take yeah throw
peace I told her hair the hair stuff
yeah but nothing else
you don't take something for your pee no
I don't and I don't need anything for my
pee pee but I never taken viagra I bet
you take pee-pee pills
I don't you take peepee hair and you
take calcium pills I don't take calcium
pills yeah because your bones
pronto my bones Dale's tried my bones
look that I've seen them what's the
density of your bones like titanium
titanium yeah my wife titanium bones
they're stupid don't worry nut job hit
you as hard as you can in your thigh he
could hit me anywhere he wants okay but
just know this know this if you guys if
you want a street fight with me yeah
pack a [ __ ] lunch bro
I'd say package you're gonna be there
why you're gonna fight all day is that
what you're saying I try there that's
gonna fall down okay good you're gonna
kill all the bacteria
you can't yeah you can okay I'm gonna I
could you think
do you really think in a crazy street
fight yeah you and I yeah that it's
gonna take that long from sunup to
sundown I'm gonna have you ever done
anything wild worth low blow yeah
all first Marlin shovel Slugger
Santino's Slugger Santino sluggers no no
you know I've heard the story that slug
- Santino let me tell you something why
my dark you have dark sightless eyes
sometime I was 13
yes I'm walked in my room and said
that's it you're grounded you didn't
clean up the house guess what I did
punch that [ __ ] and the feeder to death
it killed my mom and your mom and 13
meter to death that seems so awful you
scarred yeah here comes my bitch-ass dad
running in weird you do to your mom what
you do your dad all about you know
headlock don't beat his ass to death you
know you killed boyfriend's with your
bare hands mom dad mom dad that's where
you call your hands mom and dad mom and
dad that's what I call him that I say
you're gonna be my mom and when you're
gonna find that my parents will you go
do you want to be my [ __ ] parents and
these are my adopted parents right here
this is this is a Margie and keV Jesus
and if they [ __ ] with me dude yeah don't
[ __ ] with me so what so you know you
know I say before you say before they
say you guys say you Rogen and shops
around me Oh what it how much fun okay
right yeah now this is what I go I go
like this I go I look around I go you
guys want to dance let's dance and
that's the last thing you know but it's
not oh that's your life
so that's your last words you know put
that on YouTube this is it the West Side
Story yeah we're not gonna let you let's
dancin
it's not that me to me it may as well be
because I'm here's what's in a hat on
moving Shabbos gonna just like grab you
if we're in the circle we're all gonna
laugh when you say that dumb [ __ ]
line your last words we laugh we left
Joe DiMaggio is not he just wants to
kill you Joe's too intense Saab wraps
you up and puts and puts your your
little tiny arms behind your head you
know and then I mean Joe's just kicking
it he doesn't even need to do anything
but shop hold you down put your little
longer on your hair status and I grab
onto your your ears I grab onto those
[ __ ] car doors
right and I put out my ding-dongs I put
out the big red the big red bullet know
what's called the big red yellow and I
[ __ ] your throat shut my dick comes out
of your head it's poking up poking up
until it pops right through then oh you
have a huge [ __ ] hole you have a huge
[ __ ] hole through your oh yeah I have a
glow you have a glory okay and then all
yours Rogan like this
that's a terrible yep I don't want to
die like that that's how you're gonna
die it's gonna say he got he got a glory
hole [ __ ] into his skull and his last
words were you want to dance let's dance
yep no that's it you know buddy boys
let's dance all through SPRO cuz I
create guilt in your heart then this is
this is how I fight even though you win
I create guilt my heart you just hear
this you're gonna be talking about your
kids while I'm throatfucking you because
you have to love them because I die and
then you're responsible from actually
you know what I want your kids there to
see this oh no I want them there I want
them they'll be so scarred I want them
there and the whole time I want them to
clap while I'm doing they make them yeah
heard him her dad boom boom and I'm just
[ __ ] the propecia pills right out of
your throat fitting my ass yeah my white
orange sure you don't know what you
called it the red bullet guess what
there's murdering your throat and then
oh oh one you can't take in your own
kids why are you laughing and they're
like they're putting it on snapchat yeah
you're evil you're at seminary your eyes
are so much don't put your body in the
trunk on my car and I'm gonna drive it
out to some weird [ __ ] truck stop and
like Pacoima or some [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna set you up in the bathroom and I'm
gonna write on the wall free glory hole
and they're gonna [ __ ] your dead head
all these truckers are gonna come and
[ __ ] your dead today are they are they
are that's so that's what the term dad
had come from that that's what the
Grateful Dead fans used to do they [ __ ]
dad heads this shop is roughing his own
legs he's so just yeah no no he's read
yards he's ready to go way to [ __ ] yeah
he's ready to [ __ ] yeah this is go time
so I'm calling up Joe after this I'm
gonna say Joe we got something to take
care of this Joe we had a date after
you're done with your scene
day you gonna work again yeah you are
going back you are I don't know how I
can I take a piss break you can do
crispy before in event right take a
Pittsburgh gave a [ __ ] don't get on your
phone just because let's do some current
events with an urgency yes jump on in it
I love Davison describes online bullying
after ariana grande split oh no what
happened he released a post on Instagram
saying that he's been bullied by ariana
grande fans ever since they broke up so
fine he also has like he suffers from
like super bad depression same yeah real
anxiety saying yeah yeah I got all that
stuff in show but he's saying like
people like her fans like it why don't
you kill yourself so basically he had
come out this thing like dude you guys
are blowing me no matter how bad you do
it like I'm not gonna kill myself no
matter how many times you ask am I gonna
kill myself
you know that must've been really bad
for a guy like Pete Jackson who suffers
from social anxiety do I know I know
Pete very very well on a personal level
it's a good dude it's a great guy
Pete Pete is a great dude hilarious this
channel stuff this kind of stuff happens
to everyone that that this kind of stuff
happens to everyone that this kind of
stuff happens to do you know I mean you
date someone [ __ ] mega famous
something that the media gets ahold of
it they spin it out of control [ __ ] goes
kind of weird it gets sideways and
things have change about you the
opinions of you and then when everything
the dust settles the [ __ ] sneeze is a
[ __ ] come on snakes come out from this
yeah let's say the bad the artists of
pain now imagine this imagine having
kids and then you're kicking away daddy
what you do today like I told Pete
Davidson I made fun of him incessantly
dude can you imagine that that like some
of those people are there that's this
guy wrote a really bums me out the worst
I say this guy wrote an amazing book
that I've not read but I'll tell you why
I'm talking about it he wrote a book on
called chasing the scream about
addiction and then he wrote another book
about depression and anxiety and he
looked at some amazing stats and stuff
and he was on sam Harris's podcast and
one of the things he talked about was
they've done some really really broad
and in-depth studies on the idea that
the more you use public social media for
me
and Facebook the higher your depression
level at times the more anxious total so
so much so much of what it is when you
work in a job where you have no control
over anything that that heightened your
anxiety when you work in a job when you
would not connect it to a community huge
factors in depression exactly and that's
why they jump on social media to feel
saying I said he said social media
thinking social media or your Facebook
community is a community is like
comparing porn and sex like it is not a
kimono yeah it is knife well that's
different
it's not a connection without a
community and in it and social media is
a great way to find people who hate you
and who love you but it's all artificial
comments do you guys read any hi Joe Bob
wait I'm Way better about it now I used
to like engage in a little bit and then
I just stopped reading completely and
then if I'm flying or something like
then I have time I'll go in just to but
I'll roast some people and then get out
and you check the temperature of however
if we do a show and I like I don't need
to check this show I know this show is
gonna be a great show
because I I've been doing show so long
here I know what's gonna hear a bad show
and what they say about bad show nope
I know how I cause I always want to know
what the fans are thinking cuz I'm
usually on par with them so if we have a
guess right 10 minutes in a show I know
every show how it's gonna do typically
we yeah so long if I notice I can go
well I'll be like well let's see if I'm
right and say I can usually gauge on it
with the temperature the comments yeah
but I don't go in there like clown or
let people know here's what I found is
the best fix for me cuz I used to read
some of the [ __ ] and I [ __ ] you
know like I Rogen stuff is hard because
so many his fans are such great fans but
whenever I do that show when I first did
it I would read all that stuff and they
were so [ __ ] half of them are such
loving fans half of them are like [ __ ]
yeah dude you got a new fan of me
Santino da da da and then have them all
they want to do is critique every word
out of your mouth imagine but they care
about that person's opinion I didn't
know so I just be the same way I gave up
well by God but and then I was like the
person who's gonna reach out on
Instagram and critique a guy right who's
a successful comic or was a successful
fighter turnit success will come a guy
who's gonna reach out and say something
negative about him why would I give a
[ __ ]
you can you know you can't he's probably
working in some [ __ ] job unhappy
with his life well here's what I do I
don't know I don't know this is your Dex
this fix I don't like Twitter anymore I
don't really [ __ ] use Twitter I like
kind of stopped it's only cuz its
inundated with politics and I'm not a
political guy and like I don't want to
[ __ ] see comics debate about politics
what is not funny no it's lost all of
its fun yeah but what I'd like I've
regained some fun this is what I've done
I go hit me up if you want to get
roasted I've seen you do the dude it's
so fun because I know that these fans
know we're just having a good time we're
making they usually take shots back at
me but it's in love like it begins to
like blur these lines of like the real
reason people talk [ __ ] to you is
because they [ __ ] love you most
people dude the only reason that someone
leave a comment and go to the trouble
fan because they like you but they like
to hate you yeah cuz it gives them
something yeah so I go hey you want to
get [ __ ] roasted hit me up then I'll
light someone on fire and if it's dope
they'll go that's hilarious and they'll
retweet it or they'll hit me back with
something and I love it too I'll like
their [ __ ] I like their [ __ ] but like
he's just breaking down these fake walls
I agree it's all fake but also like have
you ever like let's say the rock post is
a post a picture have you ever looked
when looked at his comment never never
no never who looks at other people's
comments oh I don't know why we'd even
look at our that's very intriguing yeah
no have you ever clicked on page like
let me read the comments now in that
effort no I don't so why would you go
into your day I don't I don't care I
genuinely don't give a [ __ ] if I know
that about you and I actually believe
you wholehearted some people don't live
like that
yeah but some people our lives they go I
don't care but they look I know you
don't I don't care about I don't know
you I don't give a [ __ ] I like my
friends I know I'll be honest I'll check
your around and depending but I'll know
like for instance this Tyson Fury fight
Wilder I know what I'm saying is in a
popular opinion so I know there's me
some people who are very hurt by what I
say so they're gonna lash out I expect
that that's natural though but I and I
know it's gonna happen so I stay off it
on purpose they're sure that's hard
if you touch on a subject I don't care
what you say you say anything about gun
control you say anything about abortion
you say anything about you're going to
get if you say anything
about for example Donald Trump or you're
going to get both sides of you they
always have to get our listeners fall
asleep and you're gonna hate on when
you're a President of the United States
they always say that every decision you
make you're gonna make 50% of the people
happy and 50% of people totally and
that's what it that's that's a microcosm
of essentially how everybody who lives
publicly is going often it's what we
have to go through that's right you're
gonna get in again I'm sorry but think
about it you're not getting any comments
you should be worried yeah but no one
gives a [ __ ] about what you're saying is
when you're in Thomas for us especially
with the podcast the people that are
coming to our shows that they love you
and they're coming and I know they I
know those people like me you know why
cuz they'd laugh for an hour at what I'm
correct yeah so so that's what I guess
yeah I'll take that
show me the love yeah or how about how
about in New York one guy was getting
loud
I don't those fans are so loyal and
dedicated they know how hard I work cuz
they listen every time I'm on the air
they pipe from them before I even get
down hey [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
great I would do choice alright he's
only good time oh I love that [ __ ] then
I went I went before sure you're my hero
thank you guys that's my favorites my
favorite [ __ ] at a show when I hear
there was a woman in uh there was a
woman that was like really [ __ ] up
when I was in Philly and she was she was
just requesting a bit out of me that she
loved so she was a fan she was just too
drunk yeah and another girl which I
thought was really rare we know as
comics it's mostly [ __ ] dude sock
fest mostly dudes if not it's a drunk
girl with her boyfriend who's the
boyfriend brought her yeah and they're
both [ __ ] up
no dude another girl goes lady be quiet
and everybody lost and I was like that's
hilarious he or another girl yeah jump
on another girl and she goes shut up she
goes no seriously be quiet but it wasn't
like [ __ ] you and wasn't like come on
man just be quiet huh and it worked so
[ __ ] well that now I think in the
future when I do shows when someone
talks I'm just gonna go be quiet
that's such a nice quiet please such a
condescending quiet be quiet
yeah yeah and if you're an adult and you
don't get that then you gotta go yeah
but if an adult year's end goes uh gotta
be quiet
I should be I've had three physical
fights break out of my shows three yeah
geez
the [ __ ] are you doing once in the Nokia
Center downtown there is a straight-up
fight I'm physical fighting two fans one
in Florida with the people sitting at
the same table you let's go you want to
go let's go right now let's go
grope somebody are you pushing I'll go
crazy and then another one I'm trying to
think of when it was but I had three
fight Laura de Florida the Nokia Center
to LA and where New York probably Boston
how about how about was in New York the
manager of dolphin came to me they're
like we just want say we just wanna say
how happy we are because you know we
know with your previous background and
fighting stuff we didn't know what fans
you were gonna you were gonna bring you
that's funny and she goes they were the
nicest most polite fans we've ever had
here I feel like fighters real it'll be
more like that my audience is enough
it's not like it might people think the
guys with gnarly ears no no no it's it's
they're not gonna be fighting on my
audience no that's all those guys do a
lot of like jujitsu schools and you know
I get a lot of that but I think those
some of those guys might be the most
calm guys they all they get out when
they find they're nice people right even
if the crowd is broke anybody and all
that trains that fight your train I was
looking to fight people I know they
don't why would they need don'ts the guy
that does it night from day in a [ __ ]
in a you know like in a mechanic shop
and he's angry he hates his [ __ ] but
he's got a lot - he's coming - laughs -
he wants a laugh I'm just saying he's
more apt to fight I'm saying he's just
more apt to fight them out of each other
because he's got some showgirls I'm
sorry that's the third vote was two
girls so yeah why don't you take your
ugly [ __ ] ass out of here and then I
was like hey no well she's ugly and then
what she ugly though yeah well she
speaking she was not she was a little
heavy but in a good way heavys not ugly
no he's not ugly ugly is ugly sometimes
you see I see people on my shows and I
go wow
yeah really ugly and I'm happy that you
came here then I go can you bring them
out stage I bring them up on stage and I
make them out because no no no no no no
I love ugly people just as much as I
love beautiful people I see I want to
make everyone feel welcome and warm in
my shows but if I see a really ugly
person yeah i buy him a drink oh
goodness that said I got a tough life
they got to walk around like that all
the time I go get that guy a couple of
[ __ ] drinks you just have to look at
him for an hour you know I won't know
until 24 hours I don't look at people
I'm a weirdo people say that about I
don't wear
I don't I don't get anybody anymore my
gays out I'm out I'm gonna look at your
face too
I don't want to look at your face I
don't look at your face because I'm
doing this thing
I'm in full I'm in full red rocket mode
all right is what we call it the red
rocket tour is the only not access to
the red rocket tour a little it's Pierce
Brian Callens throat no the red rocket
or glory hole the glory hole tour the
red rocket glory hole Tron feature you
biography now featuring slugger sales
red rocket totally off of the mark here
or not so some parents are starting to
send their kids to rehab for a video
game addiction yep it's really bad I can
attest that my son is not allowed to be
on the iPad anymore because ever again
yeah too crazy he will but there's just
this gets crazy these kids will
disappear under this [ __ ] yeah I guess
you know what's so funny odd for the
development of video games is almost
been a negative when we were kids and it
was like 8-bit 4-bit whatever that is
you know it was so it was so fun because
it was simple now you can live inside of
the video dude don't go to Dave &
Buster's go to Dave Buzzo to Bobby Lee's
house you know dude play an arcade game
me like this shit's terrible crazy
compared to what you get at home so of
course the kids are staying home yeah
jacking off drinking Red Bull yep and
then playing for 24 hours you know I
looked at those kids at a lot of those
kids who've been coding and playing
video games all day they don't like they
actually don't vote they don't grow
their bodies are not eating yeah and
their bodies aren't being tested they're
not moving so they don't grow they stay
they stay like 10 years obviously but
there's obviously a problem with this
where kids aren't working out and
they're playing yes but there's also
another spectrum this where people think
the guys who play a lot of video games
are nerdy and like super introverted
there's a lot on that or badasses that
actually work out but they do this and
they're off not really there's tons of
money yeah and they're [ __ ] chicks
then when they're done with that they're
getting online playing video games yeah
but the truth is it's no longer just the
base time out of balance like the bomb
tell you there's all there's a heavy
portion of those game sure who are
actually like legit but this is not
talking about gamers this is just the
average child see this is just parents
are saying that the average child that's
at home
has access to iPads iPhones Xbox
Playstation the computer it's so many
free ways to play games now yeah it that
it's never it done the parents do a
little bit sure but but the Nintendo
switch like the inventions of mobile
taking with you to go that means they
want to play it all the time they have
access to it when I was a kid who's just
in the house and at the house and the
houses play at night but my that night
yeah and you're like they were outside
yeah all day because I ever played video
games during the day but at night during
asleep all the time yeah you go all
night long all night you play do their
spots right I mean totally but but
nowadays we didn't want to be indoor
what about the video games that our
virtual reality we're actually moving
shooting punch that [ __ ] no here's the
problem I had a friend of mine that was
an investor in VR he he was saying very
candidly that he's like a man we're
moving at lightning speed with VR yeah
it's still gonna take a long time for it
is just because they're it's extremely
complex and it's so much coding from
what I'm what I am really there's also a
lot of equipment right I mean it's not
even that it's more about like creating
these worlds with such depth and to make
a continually change and adapt it just
takes a lot of knowledge a lot of those
kids would much rather play fortnight or
whatever and just sit there a lot of
them don't want to they don't want to
have you done VR VR no I want to do them
I've been inside VR world and I've shot
like bow and arrow and all that so you
have to row gonna talk about for two
hours I know it's fine
it's fun it's fine but I get it while
you're like nah this is not ready it's
just not there it's not avatar it's like
you're gonna have a point where you're
an avatar though I know you're adverting
to have an avatar no no I'm saying it's
like it feels like them how great will
that be for some people do did you read
about all this stuff about the computers
that are talking to each other in
different languages you had to shut down
Facebook pulled the plug they started
speaking a different cry yeah I told you
about this right they're talking
different languages and they're saying
they can create their own no they pulled
the cord though oh [ __ ] create their own
code their only way were going into Jew
and hater no no no wishing people toward
anti-semite olds no that's Facebook but
the thing with Facebook they create this
face listen this Andrew they created
this [ __ ] and so they started talking
and they realized that humans were
downloading what they're saying they
went let's talk in this other language
that they can understand
and then people went oh [ __ ] this ain't
good to a nation when the bots when the
robots ass - it was they're like hey
there listen doses like holy [ __ ]
their followers were saying switch over
to this weird [ __ ] language database
imagine these robots are listening to us
the computer is listening to us and all
they're gonna take from this is they're
learning how to do what we talked about
doing so one day when the robots take
over and they kill us and they kill us
in very traditional ways and when they
go to manator - they're gonna remember
how I was gonna kill Brian and then Mike
listened and then I get out that [ __ ]
thing's gonna go right through Brian's
this is gonna be the black rocket is
gonna go right through Brian's throat I
don't wanna do that the machine is gonna
kill you but I don't want can I tell you
so tell the robot gene is gonna kill you
yeah you gonna say that to a robot is a
robot you can but Stan I don't want to
you're gonna die I don't want I'm gonna
I just got a phone call
why hello oh no it's your life oh [ __ ]
how long oh gosh is that a robot how
many what is that what is the fifth
today yeah yeah yeah that's near how
long do I have
it's from what Wow that's insane how
many there's four of them
No Wow no huh and they tried they did
well okay he's gonna
yay-hey he's wearing it right now what
oh my god that's it okay
all right all right bye what'd I say
no you just you know he's just saying
that um it was just you it was your life
on the line your life is on the line
imagine dying in this outfit by the way
I don't want to die myself imagine dying
in his outfit don't want to die this
outfit I would take so many Instagram
story pictures of you like the tears I
don't want dead in that bulge oh I don't
want to die this way this is why my
grandfather always dressed nice cuz he
was like well I don't want to die
looking like the casket over right yeah
he's like just put me in it now yeah but
you're gonna if you die like this
whoo yeah second reason no I don't want
my flesh showing you know what you're
yeah you want to be fully clothed when
you die I think so I won't be embalmed
they're like laughing hard like yeah
you're gonna die someday oh here I have
a whole finds gotta go back to his job
have five minutes people are dr. Kyle go
ahead sorry okay so have you guys heard
of the thought it
no no so it started as a joke where
there are people with private snapchat
accounts who will charge money for the
password to get into that snapchat and
see videos and it will be like a girls
under yeah girls and dressing and stuff
like that and somebody came out and said
that their private account was audited
because somebody try to turn them into
the IRS and that girl got audited for it
Wow as a joke and now people are
seriously trying to get girls audited
for having private snapchat ruining the
fun for everyone
hey man no one has anything better to
terrible there's no these are party
poopers
these are party poopers who reported my
premium snatched out to the IRS I'm
being [ __ ] audited so buddy though it
is well that's so funny like two hookers
don't pay taxes no I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
dude do I apologize for saying that I
know that I usually do pay taxes cash
baby I mean I sorry it's some escorts
evening ladies
by the way by the way let me let me make
this very clear [ __ ] shower and in I
am very much in support of women who
want to be in the game of sex work
that's all I want to say don't give a
[ __ ] what you do with your line I
support it but did they get a date they
don't pay taxes cuz it's cash correct
yes transit can actually turn over their
information to UM I believe do they want
to like rent house too and [ __ ] right
and they can't are you suck everyone off
to get their due Shannon that is so mean
so mean do you think that's how the
world works you think you go in to Bank
of America you suck a [ __ ] and you get a
mortgage in there well because I'm gonna
go there right after this because I'm
struggling in mine right now guys I need
one read bristle what else you got a
good interest rate what's the next one I
gotta get out of here how about the last
one Tyson if you're donating his entire
purse for the wall to fight ten million
dollars to help the poor and homeless
that's insane speech he gave
like an inspirational new right yeah man
it just made me smile so that to the
mother I love that guy he's a [ __ ]
dude you know what you know when I said
you know what I mean by that he's a dude
he's the best thing you're just a good
dude man you're the best in the world I
think he beats Anthony Joshua I think
you're the rematch can be very tough for
Wilder the draw I do have this as a drum
you do have it as a job you to nominal
fly above the fight here's the thing to
dr. Wilder when did that fight hurt her
what with what I had a broken arm a few
weeks before the fight had surgery shut
up went into without sparse are they
using that how they're using that I
don't think he's using I think it didn't
come from his team I think it finally
came out concise at these guys so he's
that he is [ __ ] dishing out ten
million dollars to the entire purse
every goddess every dollar he made from
that fight gets insane you know why is
he the most likable guy you know why
he's doing that because because he knows
this is know because he knows that he's
knows he can make more he knows he can
make off the rematch they're both me
it's like let me just do the good thing
I'm a books or not another businessman
just say there's only be a millionaire a
billionaire he just wants to help people
oh this guy I absolutely got god I love
my I love I love you almost all Mike
Tyson that's what I love Mike Tyson Fury
I love a Mike Tyson Fury poncho he was
named after Mike Tyson was correct I
think he beats Joshua I think through it
tougher Wilder in the rematch America is
fancy nice job here's my fin this people
in review Wilder knocks out Joshua and
Tyson Fury out points Joshua Wow he just
was the third out of those three do you
make bets in Vegas sometimes I have my
brother do it or buy my ejects I'm gonna
call you next time I'm gonna make some
bets on what you say please do me wrong
I think the heavyweight deciding right
now kids I gotta go
can you cut can you close this out for
me I know I open this up so strong yeah
and I'm gonna close this strong but
you're gonna be here we're gonna close
it right now with you then tomorrow
you're leaving I can't be late all right
dude I love you guys and Santina I want
to stop this now yeah you're going real
let's see where can they listen your
podcasts
you can listen to whiskey ginger
whatever podcasts are available
obviously son iTunes and all that
channel everything on YouTube everyone's
mad about it get on you do it is I know
what's coming I promise I'll figure and
also go to Andrew Santino comm for dates
I'll be in Bakersfield I've never been
up there oh you at the brewery yeah I'm
going to Bakersfield on January 19th
come to that and then I go to draft
house in DC the last weekend and Shannon
J 19 is where he's shooting his Showtime
special we won't be there what I'll be
there no I will oh where are you his
thing in Spreckels theater San Diego
shooting a special Showtime special all
right I love you guys I love you bye I
love you dude that's great keep them
cheeks tight don't forget your coat
ba-bop ba-bop ba-bop we can all relax
now Brian's left them yeah thank God
that piece of [ __ ] is gone and I
shouldn't say piece of [ __ ] cuz I don't
really mean that I love him but I gotta
tell you dude whenever I'm around him he
tense up yeah yeah cuz I just would you
know head off you know what it's either
that but he know he's gonna go at any
minute yeah yeah and here's the thing do
I like doing this podcast more with you
than with you and him together
sure do I respect and like Brian as a
comic depends day-to-day case by case by
case but i but I always love coming here
and seeing you be it's such like a light
in my life and then when Bry comes
sure it's fun --is-- you know it's fun
--is-- it's like a rainy day at
Disneyland in it yeah you're still at
Disneyland
you're still there like a little cold
and it's wet you've let me around yeah
but it's gonna be wet but it's gonna be
like wet it's gonna be um sad Mickey yes
sad wet Mickey sad wet me but I do love
coming up coming all over I gotta be
honest I'm glad you finally started your
own podcast I'm happy for you guys on
the planet thank you bro yes some of the
best artwork
you'll be doing your scene we're gonna
be what we're gonna be moving at full
speed whiskey ginger is the name of it
and I hope people listen to it and it
catches up a little bit
they will man look at it's not on
YouTube yet but you get you're headed
there we're trying we we're getting
cameras look at that's it right there oh
did someone put up video videos up it
said videos watch our other videos
that's really crazy what does that say
for videos did someone just take the
audio and throw it up looks like yeah
yeah this is Twitter oh no that's you
that's me no that's just me no so I'm
gonna put up YouTube I know everyone
gets so mad when you don't
what up YouTube stuff I know you just
started out though this video to like
our third season yeah no dude out but I
know that that's what's up right now but
it's Johnny I know that's what's up
right now I know I know what I know I
know when you don't have video it's like
you're sending mail with pigeons
I know buddy that still was very
efficient it was but because it because
if the pigeon died it wasn't supposed to
get there correct
it's in God's hands yeah I mean while
now the the postal service delivers 19
percent of my mail I don't get [ __ ]
anymore like that here is someone
stealing my mail and packages yeah so
you're in Bakersfield you said I go up
to Bakersfield of the truer the January
19th and I do a great room yet dude I
cannot wait I was nervous never done
Bakersfield and I know babe bakers with
people are gonna come the [ __ ] crowd
yeah good math yep okay don't hang out
after hours by the way if anybody bring
them whip its baby all right bring em
out bring him out bring him out the hard
whip it in your mouth all right for me
this Friday Saturday I'm in New Mexico
Albuquerque New Mexico Santa Ana casino
after that end of December I'm at the
ice house Pasadena Friday and Saturday
what are you doing December 28th 29th
nothing one Doucette
what's house yes a spider Saturday
Saturday I can perfect Santino's were
here as well here baby along with some
other funnier friends than me Edmonton
Canada is January 10th and 12th then the
grand hago so my one hour Showtime
special in San Diego Spreckels theater
get takes now tea fat cake calm we also
just released the advocating Fight Club
teas in military green they're out get
them for Andrew Santino Bryan Callen
myself this the final kid we're out
[Music]